on voudrait vous entendre pour terminer
jean louis debré sur un sujet qui marque
beaucoup l'opinion 7,1 et ans à la
question des violences sexuelles sur
mineurs un mot d'abord sur le sénat qui
a voté jeudi dernier la création d'un
nouveau crime désormais la question du
consentement ne sera plus posé pour une
relation entre un majeur et un mineur de
moins de 13 ans la question du seuil
d'âge fait toujours beaucoup débat dans
ce genre de débat justement est-ce que
vous qui était ancien président du
conseil constitutionnel est ce que le
parlement peut aller plus loin et créer
ce nouveau crime pour un mineur en
dessous de 15 ans ou est-ce que c'est
inconstitutionnel
d'abord pour redire s'est constitué un
conseil allez vous regarder le texte
précis moi je pense que dans cette
affaire-là à mineurs ne donne jamais
sans consentement et que par conséquent
il faut être au maximum dans la
protection des mineurs voilà donc je
vois pas ce qui serait inconstitutionnel
dans la mesure où déjà pour les mineurs
il ya des règles spéciales pour la
délinquance personne n'a trouvé ses
inconditionnels les ordonnances de 40 45
sont pas sont pas inconstitutionnelle on
n'a pas eu de recours
je pense qu'aujourd'hui quand tout cas
pour moi me semble-t-il
on ne peut pas dans l'état du rapport
entre un adulte et un mineur parler de
cette notion de consentement mineurs de
calage à son peu de criminaliser une
relation entre un adulte et un mineur de
moins de 15 ans oui pour moi ça me
choque pas dans la mesure où c'est la
cour d'assises dès mineurs
c'était un traître différents et pour
qu'il ya une procédure particulière mais
vous pouvez pas la relation avec un
mineur pour ce mineur j'ai commencé ma
carrière comme magistrat pour enfants de
première année et il ya un traumatisme
qu'on garde toute sa vie or ce
traumatisme peut engendrer des
comportements qui sont des comportements
déviants ou des comportements
traumatisant donc je ne vois pas comment
est-ce qu'un malheur de 12 ans 13 ans 14
ans 15 ans on peut lui demander son
consentement alors naturellement ça
dépend de la personnalité du mineur dans
mais peu importe sur
[Musique]